un margen abrumador el pnud ganó el
referendo independentista en nueva
caledonia manteniendo así la tutela de
francia sobre las islas del pacífico sur
aplicación atrás los referendos del 4 de
noviembre de 2018 y el del 4 de octubre
de 2020 los caledonias votaron
masivamente contra el acceso a la plena
soberanía e independencia en un contexto
de alta abstención por lo tanto nueva
caledonia seguirá siendo francesa 11 es
el resultado se explica en gran medida
por el boicot de referéndum por parte de
los independentistas que acusaron no
haber podido organizar una campaña justa
por culpa de la pandemia en este
municipio separatista de hecho la tasa
de participación fue especialmente baja
de
bulling se siguió el orden para los
independentistas todavía o algunos
votantes pero ahora son las dos de la
tarde y estamos en un 20 por ciento de
participación
participación de haber ganado el xi una
nueva constitución debía redactarse con
el triunfo de no se abre un periodo de
transición durante el cual tendrán que
definir el nuevo estatus de este delito
del pacífico en la república
nueva caledonia entra ahora en un
periodo de transición que está previsto
que dure 18 meses como máximo periodo
durante el cual el gobierno francés y
las autoridades caledonias tendrán que
encontrar un nuevo acuerdo definir la
relación jurídica con francia definir el
nivel de autonomía de nueva caledonia y
un proyecto de sociedad cuyo por en
société sin embargo la construcción de
un proyecto común no será fácil para el
archipiélago ya que los independentistas
anunciaron que rechazarán el resultado y
que se negarán a reunirse con el
ministro de ultramar sebastián lee con
el que llegó a la capital nueva el
viernes